simplifica 3 a la quinta entre 9 a
cuadrada por a cuarta entre a kubica así
que antes de preocuparnos acerca de la
sas podemos simplificar el 3 y el 9
ambos son divisibles entre 3 así es que
dividamos el numerador y el denominador
entre 3 tenemos entonces que 3 entre 3
es igual a 1 y 9 entre 3 es igual a 3 la
expresión que de entonces como 1 para la
quinta por la la cuarta entre o más
precisamente debo de decir a quinta
sobre tres a cuadrada por a cuarta sobre
a kubica ahora multiplicando estas dos
expresiones que tenemos que esto es
igual a 1 a la quinta por a la cuarta y
el 1 no me tengo que preocupar no afecta
la expresión entonces sería en el
numerador a la quinta por a la cuarta
todo eso dividido entre 3 dejar poner el
3 mejor acá 3 por cuadrada
a kubica y a partir de aquí hay
muchísimas maneras en que podemos
simplificar esto una de ellas a veces
denominada la regla del cociente es
aquella que establece que si tenemos a
elevada la x sobre a elevada a la ye
esto es igual a a elevada a la x menos
ye y para que podamos entender el porqué
esto funciona pensemos en la quinta
entre al cuadrado entonces tenemos que a
la quinta lo podemos escribir como a
bora bora bora bora esto de aquí es a la
quinta dividido entre a cuadrada lo va a
poner con este color a cuadrada que es a
por esto de aquí es a cuadrada ahora
claramente podemos ver que tanto el
numerador como el denominador son
divisibles por ahora es decir podemos
dividir ambos entre a por a
así que dividiendo el numerador entre a
dos veces nos deshacemos de estas dos a
y el denominador al dividirlo entre a
dos veces nos resulta uno que tenemos
entonces aquí tenemos que el numerador
es por ahora dividido entre 1 es decir
esto es igual a a por a
ahora a multiplicada por sí misma tres
veces es decir esto es igual aa al cubo
a las 5 menos 2 que es igual a kubica
teníamos 5 cancelamos 2 y nos resultaron
tres así que apliquemos esa regla por
acá y te va a mostrar dos maneras de
hacer esto entonces primero apliquemos
la regla del cociente a la quinta sobre
al cuadrado déjame indicar esto de la
siguiente manera primero haremos a la
quinta sobre al cuadrado para
posteriormente hacer a la cuarta sobre a
kubica por supuesto considerando un
tercio
adelante entonces ahora la expresión
queda como un tercio por a la quinta
entre al cuadrado a la quinta entre al
cuadrado que fue lo que hicimos por acá
esto es al cubo por a la cuarta entre a
kubica déjame hacerlo con el mismo azul
que tenemos aquí esto es a no no es el
mismo azul tenemos que esto es
no tampoco es el mismo azul ahora sí
esto es a la cuarta sobre a kubica que
es a la 4 menos 3 que es aa la 1 y por
supuesto esto lo podemos simplificar
como a kubica por a a la 1 déjame hacer
lo mejor por acá arriba aquí tenemos a
la elevada la tercera potencia por la
elevada la potencia 1 tenemos la misma
base podemos sumar los exponentes aquí
tenemos a al cubo que está multiplicada
por sí misma tres veces por una vez a
esto va a ser entonces a elevada a la
cuarta que es a la tres más uno esto
multiplicado por supuesto por un tercio
resulta un tercio a la cuarta lo cual
también se puede escribir como a la
cuarta dividida entre tres ahora la otra
manera de hacer este ejercicio era
aplicar la regla del producto sumando
los exponentes para el numerador y luego
sumando los exponentes para el
denominador así que aplicando la regla
del producto para el numerador no
aplicamos la realidad cocientes a la
vamos a aplicar después tenemos el
numerador a la quinta por a la cuarta
eso es
a la 9 a las 54 dividido entre a
cuadrada x al cubo al cuadrado por al
cubo es a la 23 podemos sumar los
exponentes tenemos la misma base esto es
a la quinta y también tenemos el un
tercio que escribimos como 3 en el
denominador y ahora y ahora podemos
aplicar la propiedad del cociente para
exponentes aquí tenemos a la novena
sobre a la quinta a la novena potencia
sobre a la quinta potencia aplicando la
regla del cociente es a la 9 menos 5 que
es a la cuarta potencia y por supuesto
también tenemos aquí el 3 en el
denominador como puedes ver de cualquier
manera obtuvimos la misma respuesta